У Берліні є унікальні місця,
де можна буквально доторкнутися
до важливого періоду німецької історії -
"холодної війни".
Ці металеві труби
показують, де колись проходив мур.
Схід та Захід Німеччини були розділені
десятиліттями. Є чимало шокуючих історій
східних німців, які намагалися потрапити
по інший бік стіни.
Дехто намагався втекти на Захід
ще до того, як звели Берлінський мур.
Як оцей молодий солдат.
Інші за для втечі рили підземні тунелі.
У Берліні їх було щонайменше 75.
Здебільшого їх прокладали із заходу на схід,
аби друзів та родичів зі Східного Берліна
визволяти у західну частину.
Одним з таких людей був Карл-Вольфґанґ Гольцапфель.
Він демонструє місце, де колись вирив тунель.
Нині тут будівництво. А в ті часи ціллю тунелю
був отой будинок на відстані вісімдесяти метрів,
по той бік муру, у Східній Німеччині.
Це була шалена робота,
за день можна було просунутися на один,
максимум півтора метри вперед.Одного разу, коли я
саме був зовсім один в тунелі, під’їхав трамвай
і я відчув, як все трясеться. Моє серце закалатало.
Я думав: зараз вони прийдуть, мабуть,
тунель викрили. Було відомо, що спецслужби
зі східного блоку шукали такі тунелі і просто
починали стріляли всередину.
Гольцапфель був рішучим противником муру,
активістом. З цими чоловіками у 1963-му він почав
копати тунель. Його рили чотири місяці. Нині,
через багато десятиліть після тих подій,
Гольцапфель зустрічається з археологом
Торстеном Дресслером. Кілька тижнів тому
археолог виявив вхід до тунелю.
Для мене це був особливий момент.
Я зміг узяти інтерв’ю в пана Гольцапфеля.
Ми говорили понад три години, і для мене
наче склався пазл: знахідка тунелю,
історичні документи та ця розмова.
Для мене особисто це було дуже важливим.
Тунель майже добудували, аж раптом втрутилася
спецслужба НДР - "штазі". Але робота була
недаремна, каже Гольцапфель.
Так, у підсумку це було дарма, але те,
що ми докладали зусиль до визволення людей,
давали їм надію, це не було дарма, це завжди добре,
байдуже, яким буде результат.
Відтоді, як упав мур, минуло майже три десятиліття.
Утім, такі знахідки, як вхід до тунелю
у Східний Берлін, показують,
наскільки жива історія в німецькій столиці.